decades ago master nur furs were able to
perform incredible feats of nur furry
these skills have long since been
forgotten but Norwegian nur fur Nils
Marcin has been trying to reinvent what
has been lost he uses forgotten
historical methods Nils realized that
where we thought this historical nursery
only works well with microwave doors and
in Nickelodeon ads about ten years ago
Neil started using nerf gun darts he
carried in his pockets surprisingly his
pockets turned out to be useless when it
came to moving fast the shooting method
is a Hollywood myth it was not common
but is still spread all over the world
why because modern er furs do not move
they stand still firing at a target
board something that was unknown in the
past this is probably due to the fact
that aiming their stationary
2-dimensional target makes the main with
one eye instead of two however placing
the dart left around the bow is not good
while you're in motion your hand is
actually on the left side of the string
so you need several movements before you
can actually shoot this is not the only
problem with nerf early today
an expert nerf press total control his
gun in all situations and must be able
to handle his gun and darts in a
controlled way under the most varied of
circumstances the old manuals told Niels
that the master nervous can shoot the
gun with both hands and still hit the
target so he began practising Niels has
managed to shoot one dart in one second
amazing Nils found he could shoot a nerf
gun in any distance even up close this
doesn't require the ability to fire fast
there are even myths of nervous that
could grab an enemy's dart and shoot it
back Wow
and the only reason Niels is able to do
it is because he spent years practicing
intensity and he has no job the hard
part is not learning how to hold the
darts but learning how to handle them
properly his test speed and accuracy at
the same time and he'll set up an
experiment where he shot incoming darts
with darts
his own some consider this the ultimate
nerve trick we do now recommend you try
this at home for more amazing feats of
mercury check out new media rockstars
YouTube page